[Música]
la profundidad de la estética
la belleza puede cambiar el futuro de un
país de una ciudad
de un ser humano
siempre me he preguntado por qué hay
lugares con una gran belleza natural
que la presencia del ser humano las
disminuye con edificaciones y
urbanizaciones descuidados y otros con
relieves más inhóspitos que las personas
embellecen a través de la estética en
múltiples formas jardines arquitectura
artes
la película la grande belleza del
director paolo sorrentino hace un
homenaje a la estética única de la
ciudad ya su protagonista se mueve con
elegancia y languidez entre su hermoso
apartamento los bellos edificios y
cuidados jardines de la ciudad
nos trasladamos a romà en méxico de
manos de otro genial director cuarón con
creó la protagonista que trabaja en el
acomodado barrio con el nombre de la
gran ciudad italiana pero cuya familia
vive en un sitio de extrema pobreza y
degradación
su paso por su barrio y la postura con
la que camina por la vida dista mucho de
la relajación con la que se desliza jeff
por roma en italia
no podemos no preguntarnos
pertenece la estética solamente al mundo
desarrollado
como nos afecta a nuestro sentido de
integridad y dignidad el estado de
nuestro entorno
veamos otro ejemplo
en una de mis clases hace varios años
escuché la siguiente historia de un país
latinoamericano
una trabajadora social
recoge a una mamá con su hijo de un
barrio pobre de las afueras de la
capital para hacer una gestión en un
barrio acomodado de la ciudad
el niño viene comiendo un caramelo en el
coche y cuando llegan al barrio elegante
quiere abrir la ventana del carro para
tirar el papel la mamá se gira y le dice
aquí no se puede tirar basura en la
calle
y de nuevo surge la pregunta nos dictan
los códigos del entorno donde no podemos
portarnos bien y donde mal
la integridad del entorno de influencia
cómo nos comportamos
tres miradas que nos muestran como el
entorno es mucho más de lo que nos rodea
primero la teoría de educación temprana
promovidas por autores e investigadores
como wista y neuro piaget
afirma que aquellos niños que
interactúan con la naturaleza con la
belleza en general en su infancia
temprana
se transforman en adultos mejor
balanceados intelectualmente socialmente
emocional y físicamente
segundo las investigaciones sobre el
bienestar de martin seligman y su modelo
perma indican que la presencia de las
emociones positivas
incrementa la sonrisa la salud las
relaciones humanas para generar un mayor
bienestar
y tercero la teoría de las ventanas
rotas
desarrollado en los años 80 ha reflejado
este fenómeno empezando con los
conocidos experimentos de unos de los
coches en puestos en varios uno muy
reprimido y otro boyante
uno de los casos de éxito de su
aplicación ha sido el metro de nueva
york que era un lugar muy inhóspito e
inseguro
con la limpieza el orden y el cuidado de
las cosas el comportamiento de las
personas empezó a cambiar bajando la
criminalidad y devolviendo a los
newyorkinos una mayor seguridad
lo que nos rodea afecta a nuestro
presente y nuestro futuro
aquí les comparto otros ejemplos de
nuestros países que hablan por sí mismos
sobre la creciente dejadez que ocurre
cuando las cosas no se arreglan
que nos lleva a dejar que nuestras
ciudades caigan en el olvido
cuando nos olvidamos de nuestras
ciudades nos olvidamos de nosotros
mismos es el poco arraigo las ganas de
salir de nuestro barrio porque no voy a
prosperar
siempre hemos creído que el futuro está
lejos cuando está justo en la puerta de
nuestras casas el futuro de nuestros
hijos
inicia en el entorno que los rodea el
entorno
la entrega muchos mensajes valores y
ejemplos no podemos ser buenos
visitantes
debemos ser buenos locales primero
cuidar el lugar en el que estamos no en
el que imaginamos querer estar
es mucho más fácil florecer en lugares
cuidados
qué podemos aprender de estos ejemplos y
que está en nuestras manos hacer con los
recursos limitados de nuestros países
para generar entornos más amigables y
agradables que generen bienestar
una propuesta
que llamamos la profundidad de la
estética
la estética que representa el conjunto
de valores relacionados con la
naturaleza y la apreciación de la
belleza y la infraestructura verde es
decir la idea que los parques unen
espacios para el beneficio de las
personas pueden ayudarnos a devolver la
integridad a nuestro entorno y generar
un mayor desarrollo y prosperidad social
ejemplos como los pruebas florecidos de
francia los mapas felices presentados en
un tête por daniele coerciã o los baños
de bosque que reducen el estrés según la
teoría japonesa requieren muy poco
presupuesto y traen grandes beneficios
por otro lado podemos ver como sí se
puede mirando estos ejemplos de nuestros
países podemos ver un parque urbano en
méjico árboles en tibás en costa rica un
verdadero transformado en jardín en
medellín en colombia
un lindo parque en chile un maravilloso
camino de jacarandas de guatemala
en definitiva todo esto nos lleva a
inferir que la naturaleza puede salvar
no solamente la tierra sino hacer que
seamos mejores seres humanos más
empáticos sonrientes y saludables
recojamos la basura y sembremos árboles
para devolver sonrisas mejorar la salud
y generar un mayor bienestar de todos
pidan a sus alcaldes a invitar a los
niños y adultos a crear su comunidad
plantando flores y árboles pidan a sus
concejales que pongan basureros iluminen
las calles pongan techos a las paradas
de los autobuses y pinten el paso de
peatones en la calle además no es cosa
de países ricos o pobres sino del amor a
la naturaleza y el respeto a las
personas en efecto la pintura blanca es
muy barata y pone las calles más bonitas
o como dijo john es una cosa bella es un
placer eterno y nuestros países merecen
un bello futuro
muchas gracias
cortado
[Aplausos]
[Música]